[Musique]
joyal
gbagbo
au nom du groupe garde
paul
ok je garde
l'exemption modère
les enfants sortent elles pop corn et
laissez moi vous conter l'histoire du
viking de l'espace tort aux dîmes sonne
ce n'était pas un homme ordinaire
c'était un dieu
après avoir sauvé la terre pour la 50e
fois tort s'est embarqué dans un nouveau
voyage
il s'est remis en forme il a perdu son
ventre est retrouvé son corps de dieu
et après tout ça mieux il est finalement
redevenu
seul et unique tome
où j'ai parlé trop vite
[Musique]
une ex-petite amie
ça fait combien de temps 3,4 en huit ans
7 mois et 6 jours plus ou moins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je perçois estimant
battus par
les seuls êtres qui importe aux yeux des
dieux
cette eux-mêmes
voici taugon serment
tous les dieux faut mourir
j'allais dire qu'est ce que tu as fait
là bas m'a beaucoup impressionné
c'était mon premier méchant
[Musique]
on n'oublie jamais sa première fois
tu ne ressemble pas aux autres dieux que
tu es
une chose pour laquelle te battre
[Musique]
voyons voir qui tu es que ton
déguisement disparaissent d'une
pichenette
au en fait trop comme d'habitude
on lui donne pas un coup de main or rien
de presse des raisins